all right so this is us watching a
Suicide Squad now with this we do it a
little different academy-award can be
award-winning should I tell you I don't
think Ranaut put that in the review
somewhere um but but this is a quick
list review so we don't really take
notes for it because with regular
reviews we have to sort of make funny
actual clip that you see with a clipless
we have to explain it well they aren't
it out to you basically so it's a little
bit more like the ideas we thought more
about the ideas and different ways of
showing and expressing it so we're we
don't necessarily need the clips but we
still kind of do the same thing well
like talk at it and say jokes - is that
even what we're watching in the theatre
I have seen it I like it more than I
dislike it but I know it's not really a
good movie he has not I think he's gonna
hit I think he's very good at a
thrilling endorsement yep we're just
going to get to watching here we go
brought to you by the letter R suicide
straight
okay so already I had to close the
curtains because the movie is so dark I
can't see the damn session let's have
some fun words never heard in a DC movie
ever took this Harley multipass is she
dreaded like a remove from film intense
multi-personality it's just immediately
the soundtrack is wind yeah all does
weird combination of fog
it's like half the women I've dated that
is why I'm here
ran the mirror on top of the pile oh
yeah black woman smiles there's our two
cents more entitled look at the Superman
who shared our values Superman shared
our values he totally took out a
military satellite that was like one of
first things he did at the end of and
look we're in the video game version
[Music]
okay when it's awesome
that's so super fun so awesome before he
even Falls he's already halfway down the
village be thanks in hell so cool look I
like the Fantastic Four movie it helps
when the first thing you do in the movie
is just stupid so much okay I'm not so
ticked at Super Series yeah we've gone
back to a traditional Will Smith movie
here it is this is a romantic comedy
fucking Batman man oh boo fuck you bad I
need a machine gun
okay you looks like a trustworthy guy
[Music]
I'm so noble they ever tell you how he
used a tendril blacoh as a human shield
totally new we want to go do it like 80%
sure you know you really would have made
an event and Superman will be better
it's JoJo's Bizarre Adventure really
when you think about it we sure made
movie out of one of these people I'm
kind of thinking the same thing is
Wednesday Addams
I see more evil Hermione except she
comprising Oh too soon the world of
flying men and monsters this is the only
way to protect our country um question
many many questions so she's the bad guy
no okay good job no the bad guy in this
is so out of nowhere in a sense it's
like what suddenly the movies like oh we
have a villain now and it's like wait it
was that okay you're a villain yet I
haven't seen anybody well they're
technically all villains but ya know
like an evil sailormoon now what are we
doing I just I haven't seen a villain
yet I am literally just like we need
these guys why I'm Superman Anna
honestly this is one of those weird
movies where the best part that movie is
when there's no story no this man can do
he will charm the hell out of you a lot
is cool this just a fry sweetie noted it
Oh will I'm still 10 back where there's
a will there's a game gonna get
continued for the phone call he's the
bad guy no the phones the bad guy it was
a more sons apartment just wonders like
does he just sit there spray-painting
haha yes and just this is crazy I don't
know not only that impressed with him no
it's another Joker he's not good he's
not bad he's just another joke yeah oh
my god hahaha she's back he's the bad
guy the lamps the bad guy you know what
rocket thing and I use them so many
times I've never found them interesting
never but Birmingham was that good of a
karate what do you mean by that we mean
by that okay Tom is part of the movie
like fuck you movie that's less with the
other guy you are so screwed yours what
do you mean what do you mean we don't
find out what yeah what so far I like a
choker uses the new technology like a
mannequin cool yeah so I'm cheese the
bag
oh really they just created this oh must
been damaged pretty much I mean come on
you get all the world's worth
supervillains together and one of them
goes nothing the items come from there's
your sky portable top tip oh my god
another sky photo what about Batman the
flash right
why were they getting those people
together thanks mommy replied mahjongg
ringing Anna Reed streets near melon
betting I have no idea what he just said
either way rather sweets like Star Fox
characters this is a woman to be way
more entertaining if she's a mallet and
it makes a cartoon noises be
entertaining if she has all of these
items rigged with speakers so they make
cartoon that that's all thinkin yeah
that'd be actually really cool what we
some kind of Suicide Squad not your
place to deny the return of the King to
be known as the Fellowship of the Ring
mortgaging of the two towers do you know
there's only one Lord the reigns of the
fuck is it I know this is because I
watch arrow but yeah so she there's no
introduction here in the movie this is
our intern what yeah how do you make a
movie called Suicide Squad and have it
be completely bloodless they betrayed it
so they can say shit a couple times I
love the smell of sellout in the morning
mind games what's that always bomb in
the neck crap listen there's only so
many names we can have over the title
quiet yeah
too quiet why isn't their own song for
the soundtrack
clearly we needed Harley Quinn's a
point-and-shoot thank God you know the
nice thing is everything in here is so
black so I'm so glad those villains
they're fighting are completely black
just like dirt on dirt we're not marble
okay I would like to be that Egyptian
god that puts all these menus together
it's like about God Oh Pat look at the
straight so metropolis is Chicago
Gotham is shop now Midway City in your
cargo Billy's like Tom DiBella travel is
are right next to each other in Batman V
Superman because it literally does the
only
this.y teaspoons oh look along you do
want to say that to every single one you
know they they kind of get the idea
Kosar again the best action scenes are
with her cuz I get here well we know why
that is ha ha let's go yeah I
legitimately don't know why we were
surprised or standing around I director
hello hello why were we doing that
I love Crocs careful phone I say has he
had a line right now like at the other
word fucking you so he broke his year
and years bow not hurt anyone because
that's you want to achieve that goal so
far do you think this know Satan tempted
Christ up the desert is like a Justin
security because you decided because
surrender script are we no willingness
or what I say about the philosophy book
admit it Rick I was right
what were you were right you're bad guy
cause Donna hey don't get high-spirited
on me and on a good day running person
in this movie is a woman in a pantsuit
okay okay human the suit firing a
machine and I kind of like it feels
really clean never be afraid of your
cake that's what I like
see you can't get to the occasion yeah I
miss let's go back and forth on that cuz
the whole day I was like that's like
your kid and breathe amazed of them like
you're anyway oh I've got some grape
soda on ice bear skin that might be my
favorite lot sofas are kind of amazing
yeah and dad what do you think of him
legitimately like wine to say for going
in and like there's a ton of things
because let her die but he comes over
and so what do you think of that I
surprisingly don't mind because I've
seen the other version so many times
yeah like a fit okay with it the suit
doesn't make me care enough don't really
even get worked up about it I know he's
so obviously not good I'm giving up on
this abusive relationship I'm gonna
start better films here's my problem
we already saw this this in shyam waste
the time I agree and like they cut it
and they didn't show that we'll save it
for later right yes yes I don't only see
I know that all the other shit the
scourge capacity I know this I know this
Amanda measles you need a miracle fuck
this movie that's kind of where I'm at
right now and it started off better but
I'm just kind of tapped out like I don't
care anymore I don't get why that was
the big oh I'm done what may treat her
like that with some big reveals yeah
like but we knew all that is she who's
like obvious I like know to melt too far
like why don't forget for the bad guys
telling you all of you don't forget
where the bad guys know Trudy um such a
horribly written line I think it's kind
of awesome is not me a beautiful I'm
just like okay you have one line and yo
how come mmm it's like the rare moment
where the comedy kicks in I'm like
that's what I wanted can you imagine if
they didn't go back and do the reshoots
- as a comedy it feels like karate
killed her husband was that sword his
soul trapped inside of it
eggs telling us not showing us moving
okay was made for the fans they know
they read the comments they don't need
to see it in glorious big-screen that
takes real more because if I'm a fan I'm
what no that's exactly what I want to be
yeah I want to see the comic book come
to life now you just say yeah that
happened with comic guru dad fuck you so
much for the fans we didn't even make a
movie we just have a giant comic that we
just show on camera and we took half of
that comic house cuz we figure you know
it already contains do the Egyptian
currently flying horribly okay where's
the president mission right then he'll
off you want to know you can't see
without the makeup like makeup sucks
anyway what do I give a shit if this
work better Joker I'd agree with that
this Joker's not that great noble
character development of in Fantastic
Four we'll call it aa thing
[Music]
oh not to draw more okay yeah I totally
forgot what that was
I totally blocked that out for my memory
like what the fuck was that why could he
do that you got to wait with the
Egyptian word for screw I don't know but
apparently these writers knew it
pork belly dancing Hermione that just
made me more angry I'm gonna movie with
the heart
blows air the blueberry you met my
friend no see if she says you hurt mr. J
then no then I would have yeah I even
see much in the way of just like oh yes
we really care about each other I mean
you have the bar scene but I don't think
that's enough for life no no I'm willing
to risk everything so that needed to
happen 40 minutes before it did and you
need to have more character development
along the way I don't know her whole job
is just being told no yeah Kitana no you
only use your powers when it's useful in
Utah shall we do how to get my gosh I
had a sword I could have done it myself
which said now I literally don't have
the balls and could have done it i am i
have seen hardly any suicides I expected
more Pinkman break him out and go in
there and when I bring out one cool fact
at it I'll do it cool hypotenuse so you
have to know this angle he will lift it
Emily know that I like that okay if this
is Batman and this is you what shot what
I have to make to get him get you out of
the way yeah just bring up a little
wound that's wrong why is that even the
ending I just thought I'm like oh okay
so that happened I didn't miss him at
all you know it'd be cooler if you
fucking ended on that guy you said you
were going to get the car
the cop who never shows up again that
movie wasn't terrible but it wasn't
really very good to me it's like I says
the first 40 maybe even 15 minutes I'm
like okay this is actually okay it
doesn't make it right
sort of gets less and less and then just
like this is what the comedy added and I
know that's what that's what blows my
mind if I if this was the commie add it
in
holy hell I want to be original yeah say
for the fans one more time it's boy a
fan yes at Suicide Squad and yeah happen
like I said we're just going to take a
lot these ideas and things we say we're
going to turn into the review by the
time you see this review already out so
you can see what made it wasn't so
that's not in and we'll see you next it
was all right I guess it's all right
you